all right I know people have been
waiting anxiously for this week's hatred
mail we're going to get to it in a
second first a reminder about what
hatred mail is it's like email for words
from your racist grandma on steroids
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom
this week's hatred mail contains two
instant favorites of mine and one
relates to the Westboro Baptist Church
although you won't actually hear the
word Westboro in this hatred mail let's
take a listen to this David Pakman is a
globalist cuck Maha God you're a kook
David Pakman hand motions are very
feminist Pakman just a dishonest person
and clear the leftist are the violent
group in America except the KKK and West
Mall burrow cults rest of terrorists and
violent group in America are funded by
the left
why do you whites and Jews always want
to control what we do what a load of
crap Pakman I think David Pakman has
mental illness put him of YouTube yes
immediately put me of YouTube I don't
know what that means but I'm gonna be
put of YouTube you'll be the head of
YouTube perhaps maybe that's what they
mean the West Marlboro Baptist Church
that is the church where they say they
pray to the god of Marlboro cigarettes
or some anything like that rather than
God hates [ __ ] actually it's kind of
interesting that bags is cigarettes
right I mean it used to mean cigarettes
to say [ __ ]
anyway the West Marlboro Baptist Church
I can tell you with certitude we've
never had anyone from that we've
interviewed people from Westboro Baptist
Church Shirley phelps-roper
and Jonathan Phelps and the other dude
that like married in Steve drain or
whatever were just joined but never
anybody from the West Marlboro Baptist
Church and the KKK and the Marlboro
Baptist Church are the only two violent
extremist groups on the right wing yeah
right oh yeah yeah yeah that's there's
no but there's no Patriot movement
people
there's no sovereign citizen people
or the Bundy type clan or any of those
there's none of that stuff those go down
it's just Marlboro and the KKK remember
you can turn hey treat male into
something positive the coupon code hey
treat 40 saves you 40% on any membership
at david pakman.com slash membership